The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
We are getting close.
We are in the last unit.
We are doing kinetics.
And we are going to talk about
reaction mechanisms today.
We had a little bit of an
introduction to that already
last lecture,
setting up to do this.
Today we are going to run
through and talk about how you
come up with reaction
mechanisms, how you evaluate a
proposed mechanism in terms of
the experimental data.
This is, again,
in Chapter 13.
All right.
Suppose you have a particular
reaction.
You know that two NO gas plus O
two gas go to two NO two gas.
And someone has come up with
some experimental data for you.
And they figured out that the
rate law for this reaction,
there is observed rate
constant, so k observed.
And in terms of the NO
concentration,
it is second-order.
And in terms of O two,
it is first-order.
And so now, you can come up
with a reaction mechanism that
fits that experimental data.
And, as I mentioned last time,
you never know for sure that
your reaction mechanism is
correct.
All you can do is be consistent
with the data.
You can prove reaction
mechanisms wrong.
You can come up with a
mechanism and show that that
cannot possibly be the mechanism
given the experimental data.
You can prove things wrong,
but you can never be sure that
you have it right.
The best you can do is be
consistent, but you can prove a
lot of things wrong.
And if you have a lot of
mechanisms and you prove a lot
of them wrong and there is only
one that seems to hold,
then there is a good chance
that probably is correct,
but you never 100% because
someone might do another
experiment and discover
something else.
But, in the problem set,
you will be saying,
yes, this mechanism is
consistent, or you will be
writing a consistent mechanism,
or you will be saying,
that mechanism cannot possibly
be true.
All right.
Let's look at that.
First let's just consider what
the overall order of this
reaction is.
What is the overall order if
this is the rate law?
Three.
I am just running through
these.
We will practice some of these
because these are good couple
point questions on the final,
and so you don't want to miss
these easy points.
All right.
If the overall mechanism is
three, the overall order is
three, three things coming
together at once to react.
Is it likely that is it one
step?
No, it is not.
What is it called if you have
three things coming together in
terms of molecularity?
Termolecular.
And those are rare,
as we talked about last time.
As I said, if you are getting
together three people,
it is usually not true that
they all arrive sort of ready to
go at the same exact moment.
Usually one person is late,
if not more.
Getting three things to react
together at the same time is
challenging, and so those are
rare.
So, this probably has more than
one step.
Then we have to try to divide
up this reaction into steps and
come up with a mechanism,
a two-step mechanism we will
try for this.
Let me leave that up.
All right.
Let's draw a potential
mechanism on the board.
And then we will try to figure
out, for that mechanism,
what the rate law would be if
that was the correct mechanism
and see if it is consistent with
the experimental data.
Again, what was the
experimental rate law is k
observed.
That is the observed rate
constant.
Second-order in NO and
first-order in O two.
We can write the reaction in two
steps, and each step is an
elementary reaction,
so it occurs exactly as
written.
In the first step,
we will have two NOs coming
together.
And the forward rate constant
will be k one and the
reverse rate constant will be k
minus one.
And it will be forming an
intermediate,
N two O two.
In the
second step of the reaction,
we will have oxygen come in and
interact with the intermediate,
N two O two,
and form, with a rate constant,
two NO two's.
And
that will give us our overall
reaction.
Now we need to write rate laws
for each step.
And since each step is an
elementary reaction,
we can write the rate law using
the stoichiometry of that step
as written.
The rate law for the forward
reaction would be what?
What do I put first?
k one.
And then?
NO squared.
What
about the rate for the reverse
reaction?
k minus one.
Times what?
N two O two.
Okay.
Let's look at each of these.
For the forward direction,
what is the order?
The overall order is two.
And so in terms of
molecularity,
what is it?
Bimolecular.
For the reverse reaction,
the order is what?
One.
And what is that called?
Unimolecular.
Okay.
Let's look at Step 2.
The rate for step two is what?
k two.
Times?
It would be O two and N two O
two, the concentration of each.
Again, we can write them exactly
as written.
Now we consider the rate of N
two O two formation,
so the overall rate of NO two
formation from these two
steps.
And we can just use second
step, where NO two is
being formed.
And so we can write this is
equal to that rate law times
two.
Let me rewrite the rate law.
And the two comes from the fact
that two NO two's are
being formed.
Because two NO two's are being
formed, this concentration is
increasing at a different rate
than the concentrations of these
are decreasing.
The book is inconsistent with
whether it puts a two all the
time, so I am not going to take
off if people forget to put the
two in this --
-- because the book should be
more consistent with that.
But, if you do see a two,
it will mean that you are
forming two of the products in
the reaction.
All right.
Now we have written a rate.
We are not equal to our
experimental rate here because
there is an intermediate.
This is an intermediate.
And an intermediate cannot
appear in the overall rate law
for something.
You are going to be spending a
lot of time getting rid of
intermediates.
Let's now leave this here and
try to get rid of our
intermediate.
I am having trouble with papers
today.
Now let's solve for the
intermediate.
And we want to solve for this
intermediate in terms of things
that are not intermediates.
We want to solve for it in
terms of reactants or products
or rate constants.
We need to consider,
then, how this intermediate,
N two O two,
is being formed and how this
intermediate is being consumed
or decomposed.
We want to figure out the net
formation of the intermediate.
And the net formation of the
intermediate is going to equal
the rate at which it is formed.
It is being formed over here in
the forward direction of the
first step, so we will write
that down.
We consider how it is being
formed.
It is being formed with the
rate k one times the
concentration of NO squared,
so that is just the rate law
for the forward direction of the
first step.
It is also
being decomposed in the first
step in the reverse direction.
It is being decomposed with the
rate of k minus one
times the concentration of the
intermediate.
That is just our rate law for
this reverse step of the first
reaction.
And it is also being consumed.
It is also being consumed in
the second step with a rate law
of k two times the
concentration of the
intermediate times the
concentration of O two.
That is just the rate law that
we wrote for this second step.
It is being formed,
decomposed and consumed.
The net formation equals the
rate at which it is formed minus
the rate at which it decomposes
minus the rate at which it gets
consumed.
And now we can use something
called the steady-state
approximation.
In the steady-state
approximation,
all it is saying is things are
in a steady state.
That means that the net
formation of this intermediate
is equal to zero,
or if it is in a steady state
that the rate at which it is
being formed is going to be
equal to the rate at which it is
being consumed,
either by the reverse,
Step 1, or Step 2.
This rate is equal to this
rate.
That means it is steady,
so it is in the steady state.
The net formation is zero.
The rate at which it is being
formed equals the two rates at
which it is being consumed or
decomposed, the rate at which it
is decaying, are equal to each
other.
That is the steady-state
approximation,
and it is a very good
approximation.
And so you can use this for all
of the mechanisms that you will
be writing.
That allows us to set it equal
to zero, or we can rearrange
these terms so that these two
are on one side,
and the rate at which it is
formed is on the other side.
Let's do that.
And I am going to take these
two and put them together and
also pull out the term for the
concentration of the
intermediate because I want to
solve for that term.
I am going to try to pull it
out and solve for it.
If we rearrange this,
then, we get that the
concentration of our
intermediate,
you pull it out from those
terms, so that leaves k minus
one plus the other
term k two times O two.
Now I have just pulled this out
from these two,
and I have moved these to the
same side of the equation.
And so that is going to be
equal to k one times NO squared.
This is the rate at which you
are decaying your intermediate,
and this is the rate at which
you are forming that
intermediate.
Now I can continue to solve for
this.
The concentration of the
intermediate is going to be
equal to k one NO squared over
((k minus one) plus (k two)
times the concentration of O
two).
Here is what the
intermediate,
then, is equal to.
And now I can take this term
and go plug it back in.
All right.
We can take the concentration
and plug it back into here,
so that whole term that we just
came up with.
And we will put it back into
that equation.
Then, if we substitute,
we get the rate of NO two
formation is going to be
equal to (two rate constant k
one, rate constant k two times
NO squared times the
concentration of O two) over (k
minus one plus k two times the
concentration of O two).
But that is not consistent.
We have NO squared
and two O two terms,
whereas, in our observed
experimental law,
there is only one term for O
two.
That is not consistent,
so something is wrong.
This is not consistent,
so there must be fast and slow
steps.
If there are fast and slow
steps, then we can simplify this
equation and make it like the
experimental equation.
Now we can go over here and
think about what would happen if
Step 1 was fast.
It is a fast and it is a
reversible step.
It is already written that it
is a reversible step,
so it is reversible.
And Step 2 might be slow.
Now we can consider,
if we have a fast first step
and slow second step,
what that would do to this
equation and whether we could
then rearrange this equation
such that it would be equal to
our experimental rate law.
When we say something is slow,
we are going to introduce a new
term.
And that the slowest step in a
reaction mechanism is called the
rate determining step.
And, for a rate determining
step, you can assume that that
step is governing the overall
rate of the reaction.
It is slow enough that the
rates of the other reactions
don't really matter.
That is what rate determining
means.
And let me just give you an
example of a rate determining
step.
After today's lecture,
you will be able to do all of
the problems on Problem Set 10.
This is your last problem set
in 5.111, and so it would be
really great when that problem
set is finished and turned in.
And so all through the rest of
this lecture thinking about,
I can go out right after class
and finish that problem set,
because you are very excited.
And by the time it gets close
to the end, you see the end of
the handout coming up.
Your books are sort of packed,
you are ready to go,
and then the minute it is
finished, you are out the door.
And you are going to some place
where you can sit down and
finish Problem Set 10.
You are moving really fast.
You might even be running.
You may be even jumping over
people in the infinite corridor
to get to the library as fast as
you can.
You get to the library and you
look for a table,
but everyone else from 5.111 is
already there,
and all the tables are filled.
You go to the first floor and
the second floor and the third.
You go to the basement and in
the stacks.
Every table is filled up with
people doing Problem Set 10.
Then you have to leave the
library.
You think Building 2,
lots of small classrooms,
they cannot all be in use.
You run over to Building 2,
but all those classrooms are
filled with 5.111 students doing
Problem Set 10.
And so eventually you get to
Building 4 and you find a free
classroom.
The minute, the second,
you find that free classroom
your books are out of your bag.
They are out.
Your calculator.
Your correct kind of approved
calculator is right there,
and you are ready to go.
It takes you maybe two seconds
to get out 10-250,
and it takes you maybe two
seconds to pull out all your
books to be ready to go,
but it takes you a half an hour
to find the table to do that
problem set.
Overall, half an hour plus four
seconds is a half an hour.
That was the rate determining
step.
In finishing Problem Set 10 was
finding that table.
What you can do for these as
well, if we say there is a slow
step, you can assume that that
is rate-determining.
And you don't have to worry
about how fast those other steps
are.
It just depends on the rate of
the slow step.
That is governing the overall
rate at which the reaction or
the process happens.
That is rate-determining step.
We can use that,
now.
And we can use that and go back
and simplify the expression that
we solved for the intermediate.
Here we were solving for this
expression, and we weren't
considering anything about fast
and slow steps at this point.
And so this is the equation
that you would get if there were
no fast and slow steps.
And then we plugged it into
this and found that it was not
consistent.
Now let's take a step back and
go back here and think about
what this expression would be if
the first step was fast,
and the second step was slow.
Here, again,
I have just put it up on the
screen what we had on the board.
We have this first step is fast
and reversible,
and the second step is slow.
Really, what we are talking
about here is we are comparing
rates for the decomposition of
the intermediate,
that is the reverse direction
of step one, with the rate for
the consumption of the
intermediate.
Which of these is faster?
Well, decomposition is faster
because this is a fast step.
And the consumption in Step 2
is slow.
What does that mean?
Well, if we write it down,
then, if the rate of the
decomposition,
this rate, the rate of the
reverse reaction,
is faster, then this k minus
one is a bigger number
than k two.
The rate of consumption here is
slow.
We are going to consider the
relative size of these numbers
and how they fit in this term,
and you can drop things out by
assuming that one thing is a lot
bigger than the other thing.
If we do this then we are
saying, again,
this is the same thing that was
on the last slide,
that the rate of the
decomposition is faster than the
rate of consumption.
i.e., Step 2 is slow,
Step 1 is fast.
What you are saying is that k
minus one is a bigger
number.
That rate constant is a bigger
value than the k two
term.
And, in the bottom of the
equation here,
in the bottom of this equation
for the intermediate,
we have a term k minus one
and we have the term k
two times the concentration of O
two.
And now, if you are saying this
about the different rates of
this reaction,
if you are saying this is fast
and that is slow,
this is a big number,
that is a small number.
If you have on the bottom here
a really big number plus a much
smaller number in comparison,
this smaller number is not
adding much to the bigger
number.
And we can just cancel that
term out.
We can just say it is so much
smaller than the other,
we are not going to worry about
it, and we are going to get rid
of it.
Now our expression would look
like this.
The concentration of the
intermediate is k one times NO
squared over k minus one.
We can rearrange this and think
about, does this look familiar
to any of you in terms of what
we have seen before.
We can rearrange it to look
like this.
And what is this term?
What is this all equal to?
K, the equilibrium constant.
It is equal to K one.
This is just an equilibrium
expression.
And, if you go back and look
over here, you will see that if
you are going to write the
equilibrium expression for Step
1, products over reactants,
that is what you would get.
And also, we saw last time,
that you can express
equilibrium constants in terms
of rate constants.
And the equilibrium constant
for a reaction is going to be
equal to the rate constant for
the forward reaction over the
rate constant for the reverse
reaction.
And at equilibrium those rates
are equal to each other.
So this is just an equilibrium
expression.
When we assumed Step 2 was slow
and Step 1 was fast,
we can now solve for the
intermediate in terms of an
equilibrium expression.
Let's consider why this is
true.
Okay.
When you have a fast first step
followed by the slow step,
the first step is pretty much
in equilibrium.
The first reversible step is in
equilibrium.
And you can kind of think about
it in terms of this diagram.
Here you have reactants going
to intermediates,
and this is fast and
reversible.
Then the second step,
the consumption of the
intermediate,
is slow going to products.
If this is really pretty slow
and not much of the intermediate
is being siphoned off to
product, more of it in fast
equilibrium is going back and
forth with the reactant,
then that creates sort of an
equilibrium expression.
It is not perfect.
Some of it is being siphoned
off, but more or less you can
consider this in equilibrium.
Again, if you have a fast
reversible step followed by a
slow step, you can assume
equilibrium conditions.
That is going to make your life
easier in terms of solving these
expressions, because you can go
right to writing an equilibrium
expression, then,
for your intermediate.
Now, we can go back and
substitute.
We have this term,
now, for solving for our
intermediate.
Or, you could write rate
constant k one over k minus one.
Or, you could write big K,
the equilibrium constant
K one.
These are equal to the
concentration of the
intermediate.
We can put this term back in
here now.
This was, again,
what we wrote in the very
beginning for the formation of
NO two.
And we can substitute that back
in.
And we can have it in terms of
the rate constants or using an
equilibrium constant in there.
Those would be equivalent.
And all of these k's,
in terms of the experiment,
are going to be grouped
together as a k observed.
You usually are not going to
measure all the individual rate
constants.
You are just going to have some
overall rate constant that you
do measure, an observed rate
constant.
And so if you write then either
of these in that form where all
your k's just get grouped into k
observed,
then you see that that is
consistent with the experimental
data.
That mechanism works.
A mechanism works that has two
steps, the first step being fast
and reversible and the second
step being slow.
We don't know for sure that
that is the mechanism,
but it is consistent with the
experimental data.
Let's look at another example
now.
We are going to look at three
different examples.
Here, there is a proposed
mechanism that is very similar
to the one that we just looked
at.
Now, we are going to try to do
this problem in a more efficient
way than we did last time,
which is kind of work through
it the way you will when you are
doing Problem Set 10 really
fast.
All right.
We have a two-step mechanism,
one that is fast and reversible
and a step that is slow.
The first thing you want to do
is write the rate laws for each
of the individual steps.
For this one,
what is the rate law for the
forward reaction?
k one times O three.
That is
for the forward reaction.
For the reverse reaction,
we have k minus one times O two
times the concentration of this
intermediate O.
Let's look at the second one.
Here, we have the rate k two
times the intermediate O times O
three.
Now, the rate is going to be
determined by this slow step.
And we can write the equation
for the formation of O two
from this last step.
And we could do that whether it
was the slow step or not.
We did that before as well.
If we write the formation of O
two, it is being formed
in the last step from O and O
three.
We are using this rate law.
And, again, we have a two in
there because,
like the last example,
two things are being formed.
We have two molecules of O two
being formed.
The rate of formation of O two
is two times k two
times this intermediate times O
three.
If there is no intermediate in
the expression,
we would be done,
but there pretty much always is
going to be an intermediate in
the expression.
We need to solve for that
intermediate.
O is an intermediate,
so you need to solve for it in
terms of reactants,
products and rate constants.
Again, here we have this step
that we saw before.
The first step is fast and
reversible, the second step is
slow, and so you can assume,
approximate that the first step
is in equilibrium.
And so you can solve for the
intermediate in terms of an
equilibrium expression.
What is the equilibrium
expression for the first step?
K would be equal to?
I will just put it down here.
You can write it in terms of k
one over k minus,
products,
O two times O,
over reactants,
O three.
That is just our equilibrium
expression.
We have it in terms of the rate
constants and in terms of this
expression for products over
reactants.
And now we can take this and
rearrange it to solve for our
intermediate.
We would have this,
we would bring the O two
down to the other side,
we would bring the O three
up here,
which leaves us with k one
times the concentration of ozone
over (k minus one times the
concentration of oxygen gas).
That was a lot simpler than
what we did over here.
And so you can feel free,
if you are told there is a slow
step and a fast step,
just jump right to that and
solve it in terms of the
equilibrium expression.
It will save you some time.
You should come up with the
same answer if you do it the way
that we did it in the first
step.
And sometimes you will have to
because you won't know about
fast and slow steps.
Now we can take this term and
substitute it back into the rate
law for the formation of O two
gas.
And so we had two k two times
this intermediate times O three.
We put this term in for our
intermediate,
and we get two times k two
times k one ozone squared over
(k minus one times O two).
And so this would be the rate
law for this particular
mechanism.
If that is the rate law for
that mechanism,
you could think about,
what are the orders in this,
and could you experimentally go
back and look and say,
okay, is that consistent with
the mechanism?
Let's take a look at what we
would predict from this.
First, we could also write this
in terms of k observed and group
all the k constants together for
k observed, and that is times
ozone to the two and O two.
If we look at this,
if we were going to design
experiments for someone to do,
what would we predict to sort
of prove that that is,
in fact, a correct mechanism?
What is the order,
based on this rate law,
in terms of the concentration
of O three?
Two.
If someone went into the lab
and doubled the concentration of
O three, what should they
observe happen to the rate?
They should observe four times
the rate.
What is the order in terms of O
two?
What is it?
Minus one, right.
If you doubled the
concentration of O two,
what should happen to the rate,
keeping everything else the
same?
It should be half.
This is the kind of thing that
can be experimentally tested,
whether it is consistent.
And what is the overall order,
then, of this reaction?
It would be one.
And so if you doubled both
things, what should you observe
happen to the rate?
Yeah, it should double.
You could go back and sort of
test this.
Okay.
Let's look at one more example.
This time, we are not going to
make a proposal ahead of time
about fast and slow steps,
but we are going to work out
what the overall rate law for
this is without fast and slow
steps and then go back and
consider which step,
or any, are slow.
Now we are going to go through
the long way and do this problem
and then think about what we can
learn from it in terms of we are
given an experimental rate law.
And once we see how this works
out, we can think about whether
a step is slow or not.
First we start the same way,
and we are going to write the
rate laws for each of the
individual steps.
Again, they are elementary
reactions.
Steps in a mechanism are
elementary reactions.
We can write the rate law
exactly as the equation is
written.
What is the rate law for the
forward direction,
here, of Step 1?
First we have k one times NO
concentration times Br two
concentration.
That is the forward.
And in the reverse,
we have rate constant k minus
one times NOBr two.
For step two,
we have rate constant k two
times NO.
There you go.
So, you know how to do these.
We have that.
Now we are going to be looking
for the overall formation of
NOBr, and so we can write this
just using the last step.
We can use that rate expression
for that last step.
The formation of this.
And we are putting a two in
because, once again,
there are two of these being
formed in that last step.
Again, we could just use the
rate expression for the last
step.
And there is a two in there,
because two are being formed.
That is the rate of formation
of NOBr.
Now, we have an intermediate.
This is being formed and is
being consumed,
so we need to solve for the
intermediate.
There cannot be any
intermediates in our overall
expression, so we need to get
rid of that.
So, it is intermediate and we
need to solve for it.
Now, we cannot go and just use
the equilibrium expression for
the top, because we don't know
anything about fast and slow
steps.
We don't know that that is
going to be a good assumption.
Let's just write it out the
long way and then come back and
consider whether that is
consistent with the experiment
or we have to do some
modifications.
We are going to solve for this
in terms of reactants and
products and k's.
Now we want to consider the net
formation or the change in the
concentration of this
intermediate.
The intermediate is being
formed in the first step,
so we can write down the rate
expression for how it is formed,
which is just this,
k one times NO times Br two.
This is how it is being formed.
It is decaying in this second
step, in the backwards step,
so we can put that in.
We have a minus sign here,
--
-- because it is going away by
the rate expression of k minus
one times the concentration of
the intermediate,
and it is also being consumed
in the second step.
It is being used up in that
second step, so we will put that
term in here.
That is minus k two times the
concentration of the
intermediate times NO.
It is being formed in one step,
and it is being consumed in two
different steps.
Now we can use the steady state
approximation,
which says that the overall net
change is zero.
We can set this term equal to
zero.
It is a steady state
approximation.
That is the same as saying that
the rate at which an
intermediate is formed is equal
to the rate at which the
intermediate goes away.
We can rearrange these terms,
bring these on one side of the
equation and have this one on
the other.
Rearranging,
then, we moved these onto one
side and the formation to the
other side.
Now, we can pull out the term
for our intermediate.
Take it out here,
that leaves k minus one.
that leaves k two and
NO.
Again, this is the rate at
which it is being formed.
And now we can solve for the
intermediate.
When we solve for the
intermediate,
we take this term and divide it
by that term,
and we get this expression.
That is solving for the
intermediate.
The next step is to take that
intermediate and plug it back
into the initial equation that
we had, the formation of NOBr,
and that was two times k two
times the intermediate
concentration times NO.
Now we take this whole term and
put it back into this term,
and we get this expression
here.
All right.
This expression now is not
consistent with this
experimental rate law,
so there must be fast and slow
steps.
Now, let's consider what is
going to happen if the first
step is slow and the second step
is fast.
Again, you are considering what
is happening on the bottom of
this expression.
You are asking,
how does k minus one
compare to this k two NO
term.
And so if you say that the
first step is slow,
then k minus one is
small.
If the second step is fast,
that means k two NO
is a bigger term.
If this second step is fast,
the rate constant for the
second step is a bigger number
than the rate constant for the
first step.
And so what you can do,
then, is you can say,
okay, that is small compared to
this, so we drop out that term.
If we drop out that term,
can we cancel anything else?
What else can we cancel?
We can cancel k two.
What else?
We can cancel out one of the
NOs.
And that leaves us with this
expression here.
There is the expression again,
two times k one NOBr two.
And that can be written as k
observed.
And, look at that,
it is consistent with the
experimental rate.
Now let's just check the other
way to make sure one should be
right and one shouldn't be right
---
That we can get the answer if
we go the other way around.
This is consistent with the
experiment.
And the overall number of this
is two.
All right.
Now, let's look the other way
around.
If the first step is fast and
the second step was slow,
that would mean that k minus
one would be a lot
bigger than the k two
term.
k minus one,
rate constant for the first
step.
k two,
rate constant for the second
step.
Fast.
Bigger than this.
And so then we can take this
term out.
Can we cancel anything else?
No, you cannot cancel anything
else.
This is the expression.
We can put that down here.
We can group the k terms to k
observed.
And so this is not consistent
with the experiment that you had
before.
That way doesn't work.
You can write out the whole
thing and then think about
whether they are fast and slow
steps.
Again, you will be asking the
question, which of these terms
is bigger than the other term?
What is the fast step?
How does k minus one
compare to k two?
You can make the
simplification.
And only one should be
consistent.
One mechanism should be
The other one should be
inconsistent.
Okay.
Now you can do Problem Set 10.